these quests are a challenge for these
photographers but they're also
a way to help them frame their
experience all three of them bring
something unique
i think that's what's so rewarding about
these assignments
they were put to the test people
surrounding them they were trying to
really express themselves as
photographers
let's look at some pictures yeah now we
have to judge each contestant on all
three quests
and in the end the photographer who wins
this competition is the one
who inspires and moves us the most all
right well let's bring them in
so good to see you guys again of the
week okay the unique reflections
quest that was actually my hardest
challenge
when i chose the santa monica pier i
thought the rides themselves would
reflect and
they didn't but i think i persevered
through it and got some really great
shots
here we go this is my favorite picture i
just thought it was a very iconic image
and that it really had a strong visual
narrative to it
why is that it's got the end of the
trail sign
and then it's got people in the
left-hand side and they're really
enjoying the pier and you've got the
happy couple
i think it really like depicts the fun
atmosphere that is there
what is it that you wanted to show us as
a photographer
that i'm artistic and really driven and
i enjoyed it it was so much fun
nailed it everything that you said were
your priorities and hopes
come through in photography thank you so
much for inviting me on that journey
thank you
i've been going into all of this with
confidence because i think that shows
that i'm confident in who i am and as a
photographer
i think that can only help me okay nina
we'll score
all of your three quests but let's start
with your uplifted quest
the connections between strangers in
different age groups
that is really uplifting to me and so i
found
that i was forgetting to take the photos
and just sitting down and talking with
people
just the look on her face i feel like
this is the definition of uplifted
as we sit here and kind of teary eye on
our side of the table it's so nice
then you capture these beautiful
pictures he said that you almost
forgot to take photographs i would
rather hear someone say that
they forgot because they were being
human than the opposite which is
i forgot to sit and be with these people
and talk to them
what was the thing that you wanted us to
know about you as a photographer
i really put my heart and soul into
making a connection with people
and that's really important to me i feel
what you're talking about and it's so
nice to see your pictures yes
thanks so much that's one of the biggest
compliments i could ever receive if
national
geographic is feeling connected to what
i put into my photos
so why don't we jump right in let's look
at spirit of takumi okay
i think that was my favorite as a five
image set
everyone was very focused on their
artwork and it made it really easy to be
a fly on the wall
you seem to have a deliberate way in the
selection of the pictures that you
decided to show to us
yeah i see these two images as sort of
like setting the stage of where you are
and
this is what they do and this one kind
of wraps up to me like what stained
glass is
all about it's got all the elements in
it more broadly
tell us a little bit about what you were
hoping to teach us about your
photography i think i'm really
fascinated
with relationships like the
relationships of the subjects that i'm
photographing but then also
with the relationship my work has with
its viewer
thank you so much for teaching us about
your vision
my dad was asking me are you happy with
the work that you've done and
it's the best i could do so i guess i am
i think we have some truly difficult
decisions to make now
how about we start with nina she
has the heart and i feel like she's
proven that very clearly
i was just really inspired by what she
brought that intimate touch to that
young hand
she's got the right ideas going in it's
just making sure she can
execute one thing i would bring to the
table is almost each image
is shot from the same angle and maybe
that's because she was caught up in the
moment
but it would be nice to see her move a
little it's looking better let's look at
that
reflections yeah she admitted that this
was the most challenging for her
it all started to come to life and she
found those reflections that she was
looking for
the only real show coming is that i
think that when she interpreted the
assignment
of reflection it feels to me like she
only interpreted sort of the more
literal part of that i don't feel as
much
about the people and who they are and
how they fit into this
environment and i know her strength is
her color it's a little hard
and uh bright for us geographic kind of
dials it back
i think overall though she was very
successful
[Music]
all right guys so sam his takumi
he nailed the quest pretty thoughtful on
how he approached the subject
make the artwork come to life these were
not accidental choices i see something
that was done with purpose
it feels a little incomplete he's
documented in detail
encourage him to loosen up and be a
little more free help us
really feel what it's like to be there
yeah
okay i know this is not gonna be easy
but i think it's time now we have to
really dig in and make a decision
you know with the judges it's really
hard to know what they're looking for
specifically
an artist's objective so whether i'm
gonna be the one that they choose i
don't know
i'm definitely nervous about the judging
process lots of time to second-guess
what i chose
but it's out of my control now it feels
really good to be done but i'm also
kind of sad that it's over i think i'm
just excited to
to see what happens
you